(Robert): Rebellion!
The crimes of House Targaryen
were too heinous to go unanswered.
The noble Houses of Baratheon,
Stark, and Arryn,
united to oppose and overthrow
the line of the cursed dragon kings.
While Ned Stark and Arryn secured
an alliance with the Tullys of Riverrun,
I called the banners of Storm's End
and rode out in force against the Mad King
and his minions.
Gods, those were some battles!
Our first victory occurred at Summerhall
where I faced off against
an army of dragon loyalists
and won three battles in a single day -
three in one day!
Seven hells, that was a glorious day!
We tried to take Ashford Castle
in the Reach,
but the Tyrells beat us back.
We had to regroup.
My army was pursued north by Aerys' army
and took refuge in the Stoney Sept
in the riverlands.
When the Targaryen army entered the town,
the sept bells tolled,
a signal to the townspeople
of the battle that was to come.
As the Targaryens searched
from house to house for me,
the combined forces of Ned Stark
and the Tullys swept into the city.
Gods, what a day that was!
It's now known as the Battle of the Bells.
We overwhelmed the Mad King's forces
and sent them scampering
back to King's Landing.
Aerys' son, Rhaegar,
who started the whole damn thing,
finally emerged from hiding in the South,
and assembled his own army to face us.
As for the Mad King,
he must have been pissing himself.
The battle that would decide the fate
of the Seven Kingdoms
occurred at the crossing of the Green Fork
of the Trident river.
Rhaegar commanded the royal host,
which was some 40,000 strong.
My forces were outnumbered
by nearly 5,000 men,
but that didn't matter.
They were fresh,
but we were battle hardened
and had justice on our side.
As the battle raged around us,
I faced off with Rhaegar -
the stag and the dragon
right there in the ford of the river.
I fought with the fury of ten men,
raining blow after blow
upon that vile prince
before burying my war hammer in his chest.
I hit him so hard,
the rubies on his armor broke free,
flinging them into the stream.
They call it the Ruby Ford now.
With that scum Rhaegar dead
and the royal army shattered,
our next move was
to make for King's Landing.
But I'd sustained a few wounds
in the battle and was unable to ride.
I sent Ned Stark to the capital
to face the Mad King
and make him pay for his crimes.